bon ça va ça va fatigué on est fatigué
j'ai un truc qui va te réveiller moins
bon ouais voici dieudonné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui c'était une blague
obama
donc voilà je tenais drame non c'est le
dieudo célébrer diallo mais ce soir il
est venu sans djellaba à
jihlava quoi c'est vrai je voulais venir
avec une kippa je veux maintenant je
commence par gedo
qui commence l charrier sur l'équipe
mais jamais en sortir bon alors je suis
très heureux de vous voir tous les deux
si longtemps nle bah oui je suis content
parce qu'un jour
notre temps avec ton petit regard là que
j'aime le bien que tu me faisais pareil
tu sais que tu vas me faire pleurer oui
moi je le sais bon comment ça va tous
les deux alors
on va faire c'est mon choix maintenant
comment ça va
bah disons que j'ai vécu des choses des
choses fait
des choses pas évident
ok alors qu'on était lui moins hommes
étaient comme deux doigts de la main
grâce
tradition le chien s'était retrouvé
que j'ai vécu des choses extraordinaires
et que
je te
[Musique]
alors la seule question que j'ai cheveux
blancs souriante à gattaca
on peut parler des chouhada près
la seule question tu as toujours ta
crêpes toi
est ce que vous voyez des fois c'est vu
ouais exceptionnellement bas c'est moi
qui ai un petit peu brisé la glace coin
qui ai téléphoné c'est vrai que j'ai été
bon quoi j'étais un peu reclus j'ai fait
la campagne aussi je vais pas tout à
fait sûr la capitale dont été
non pas si à l'époque où je déconne il
l'était en grotte
non ils étaient 1 cavernes et puis je
pense que tu te
sers téléphoné parce que je me suis dit
que comme on s'est envoyé un petit peu
d'aidé vannes médiatiquement 20 par
médias interposés je me suis dit que
c'était dommage quoi il ya quand même
une amitié il ya quand même sept ans dix
communes
beaucoup de grands spectacles on sent
beaucoup de banlieues il avait fait
passer c'est que systématiquement les
gens qui viennent me voir avec qui je
parle après spectacle
y a pas un jour où on ne dit pas alors
quoi tu étais pas avec la multiple a
enfin bon on est très content il ya des
gens ont vraiment des références du duo
quoi j'ai proposé à lévis tout à l'air
de faire un duo avec dubosc il n'a pas
voulu alors tu vois pas changer dit oui
oui j'étais complément de la personne
avec qui je pourrais revenir voilà c'est
cette personne enfin après qu'on lit
évidemment fait tout ce qu'on lui a
retiré toute la partie du cervelas
toute la partie politique là que vous
voyez ici la partie provocation là et
l'antisémitisme et
alors seulement
j'ai encore répondu à une interview par
téléphone tout à l'heure légale oui je
dis j'aille à los angeles - tard les
jeux des bombes et des choses
vont aller dans ton pour te donner un
petit coup d'oeil c'est vrai que moi ce
que j'aime chez
ce que j'aime chez cette personne c'est
l'artiste c'est vrai que bon tu as été
un petit peu loin de temps en temps tu
reconnu pour moi j'ai toujours su que je
n'étais pas
bon seulement je te fixes j'ai pas peur
de l'autre
ce que j'essaye de bavans bon ça
évidemment gagner il ya des hauts et des
bas comme partout par contre on pas moi
je n'ai jamais fait qu'il y ait des
tests la population noire ne va jamais
heurter par
bon sens et c'est un fait qui étaient
ensemble et val du côté français c'est
vrai que c'est amusant que fidh
allemande avec le temps les choses se
sont taquinés pas ça fait partie du jeu
un peu forte en entendant la taxe que
j'ai fait que je
n'oblige pas répéter
non mais moi j'ai pas l'impression
d'avoir été loin du ministre mais c'est
vrai que je me battre
chose qu'ils peuvent héberger des
échanges la sensation d'appartenir à une
communauté
n'appartient à aucune autre communauté
que l'humanité je sais ce que j'ai dit
bonjour alors que je peux répéter oui
aucune autre communauté que l'humanité
tu le disais je me demande même si une
différence entre les hommes et les
femmes tout le monde bruce est la
dernière frontière que je reçus en train
de remettre en cause mais bon je fais un
peu de mal quand même s'acquitter du
réflexe est de faire un dessin la
différence un truc bien à la têt la
partie pour monet rouaix
marielle je dis pas qu'il ya des détails
de
passion peut encore parler de taille
mais il faut que je fasse attention
c'est vrai que je pense qu'aujourd'hui
et c'est super d'ailleurs on est dans
une période où entre l'homme et la femme
c'est un peu le sujet d'ailleurs de mon
spectacle mais
la frontière est de plus en plus plus en
plus étroite et puis un jour alors
laisse paraître à rien et humains autre
chose ce qui m'apparaît indispensable
vous en voulez tous les deux non non non
mais c'est vrai que moi j'ai un rapport
affectif avec les gens et j'en avais un
très fort avec dieu dos et il ya
certaines choses qui m'ont je me suis
sentie trahie quoi donc pour moi ça a
été c'était difficile de cette
séparation mais pour lui aussi le montre
pas mais bon voilà quoi alors que j'ai
chialé je me suis mis à chercher
les concevoir en 10 occasions mais on
est les mêmes si je vous venez voir mon
spectacle si vous allez voir le
spectacle de dieudo il ya des
personnages qui sont qui sont qui nous
appartiennent et puis qu'on a pris
séparément j'ai pas une façon de
s'exprimer comme ça c'est un petit peu
la patte et elie et dieudonné ce que je
dirais c'est à dire des personnages qui
et qui exprime des vérités mais qui sont
en même temps dès que je vais bien dieu
doit
bien en tout cas on vous restez avec
nous dieu de m'exprimer ce coma parce
qu'il est venu il n'ya pas longtemps jo
deux os comme un garde est là la bande
annonce de 200 spectacles divorce de
patrick la la la main d'or
[Musique]
vous avez à faire des trucs ensemble
ben on en a parlé
je sais je sais pas justement je ne t'ai
pas rappeler tu l'as remarqué écoute ce
que je propose est lisse que je te
propose c'est que je sais que tu
participent au téléthon avec axel est la
marraine du téléthon alors je vous faire
une proposition moi je tête y aller pour
une fois et voilà et pourquoi vous
feriez pas un sketch où les deux juste
pour faire gagner de l'argent à des
lettons
basser on peut pas refuser
mouais moi je suis d'accord
sarret bombesque et d'il y a et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce
bleu